And now the old scout master.
The new patrol leader is very concerned about making sure that their first camping trip is absolutely perfect,
And so he makes sure that he plans very, very carefully.
He makes sure that each patrol member has a list of things to bring,
and they have a grub master who's going to take care of making sure that the food gets there
and then coordinate getting it cooked.
And he decides that, just to be sure, he's going to make sure and test every single piece of gear
with the patrol quarter master before they leave.
After all these elaborate, lengthy preparations, the patrol heads out on their hike
and they settle in and they set up camp and they go to cook dinner.
And the grub master comes over to the patrol leader and says
the matches you gave us don't work.
And the patrol leader says they must work because I tested every single one of them.
Alright, this is podcast number 161..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at this week's mailbag.
Chris Hopkins is with the Hudson Valley Council and he wrote in to say:
I'm trying to locate the person that created the merit badge infographic on your site.
It's a resource I'd like to share with our leaders.
And I did get back to Chris and our conversation resulted in a high resolution PDF
of the merit badge blue card infographic that is on the site at scoutmastercgcom.
that makes it really easy to print and to share.
And any of the resources- the podcast, the posts, the infographics,
anything you find on scoutmastercgcom is there to be freely distributed
and shared with scout leaders.
So do go ahead and make sure you do that and take this as permission.
You don't even have to ask, okay?
Thanks, Chris.
Thanks for being in touch and I'm glad you found that infographic useful.
Bob Dawson is an assistant scout master with Troop 316 in Holland, Michigan,
And he wrote in just to say: thanks, all you do for scouting.
Thank you, Bob.
Bob was looking for some help with the podcast archive
And you know, since the site redesigned,
I'm working on upgrading the podcast archive a little bit,
but you can find it easy enough.
When you go to the website you'll see a podcast archive link
in the upper right-hand corner.
That'll take you to a list of podcasts.
You just click on one and it opens up a player in a new window.
You can listen to all 161 podcasts that way.
Thanks for being in touch, Bob,
And thanks for the kind words.
Jim Herman is the scout master of Troop 99.
He's also a den leader for Den of Bears in Pack 90
and will be a tiger leader soon,
And Jim says that's the youngest of his four boys.
I haven't been on the site in a few months.
I follow you through email subscription.
The new format's great and I appreciate all you do with this resource.
Lately I've taken to sharing articles with my Troop parents.
Your site has probably been the most influential single resource
I've had in the last few years
And I figured the more I share with my scout's parents,
the quicker they'll get on board.
Thanks again and keep it up
Well. thank you, Jim.
I certainly appreciate hearing from you.
I'm glad you're finding things useful.
Shane Lehman is with the 63rd Ottawa Ontario, Canada scout group.
He said I stumbled across your podcast about a week ago.
Shane, I really do you know apologize.
I try not to leave the podcast out there
where they are an impediment to travel.
But yeah, it was a joke.
I try.
I must admit I was not sure what to expect.
I've had limited contact with the BSA Troops
but I found the podcast very informative
and planned to listen regularly.
Scouting really is an international brotherhood
And you're right, Shane,
And thank you so much for writing in
And I do appreciate the kind words.
Justin Ross Day is in the first Model Warrie Cub Scouts
and first Win Chelsea Cub Scouts,
And I love every minute.
I am a Cub Scout leader in Australia
And, even though our scout ways are slightly different,
I can connect with a lot of what you say.
I run two groups in a place called G-Long in Australia,
But I'm now coming up to two years in the groups
and I use your common sense as a guide.
Thanks for listening.
I really do appreciate it
And following right up on that,
Richard is a scout leader with Second Bankstown Scout Troop.
He says I'm a relatively green scout leader from Australia.
I just wanted to say thanks and let you know
I'm learning a great deal from your blog and resources.
In our troop I'm training three new assistant leaders
and I've directed them to several of your articles,
which they found very useful too.
In any case, please do keep up the great work
and know that your positive impact is being felt all the way down under.
Cheers.
Well, cheers to you, Richard.
I'm glad to know that this stuff translates into Australian.
Yes, I am,
Thanks.
Clegg Warpel wrote in to say
I'm glad I found your site. started with the podcast 40
and found myself wanting to join in the conversation.
I always tell adults that if they feel like
they aren't doing much of anything
then they're doing a good job.
I get very excited about troop elections
because of how well they work.
The hard part is telling other adults
not to worry when some of the elected scouts
don't follow through.
Good job,
I have a lot of listening to catch up on.
Well, thanks, Craig.
Yeah, you know, it's not that easy sometimes
and boys are boys and they don't necessarily follow
through the way we adults should.
but they're learning stuff
and that's the important message to get out of it all. right,
Rob Stock is in the Lewis and Clark Council
in the Great St Clair District with Troop 11..
He said: thank you very much for the answer
to my email question.
I was hearing a little voice in my head
echo basically your reply
and I really appreciate the website too.
Well, thank you, Rob,
And you know you can email me with your questions
and comments at Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutMasterCGcom.
Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
I want to remind you that this Sunday, May 10th,
is our next Scout Circle. Get Together
and you go over to ScoutCircleorg,
ScoutCircleorg,
and you'll be able to view a live video presentation
and discussion with Frank Maynard.
Frank is the author of Bob White's Blather
and he is a long-serving Troop Committee Chairman
and he'll be on Scout Circle Sunday, March 10th,
from 9 to 10 pm Eastern Standard Time-
ScoutCircleorg. go on over there
and you'll have a chance to listen to Frank
and then ask him questions,
and I'm sure it'll be a great conversation.
Before we go any further, let's listen to this.
It's March and March means that there are new Scouts
because the Weevilos have crossed over
and there are parents all over the country
getting a list of gear that they're supposed to go out
and get their Scouts so they'll be equipped
for their adventures with their new Troop,
and what are they going to do?
Well, I've got a great idea for you,
and here to talk with me about it
is Bill Fleming from KhanahoCreekcom.
How are you doing, Bill
Clark? we're doing fantastic,
and are we ever looking forward to a great camp and season?
Here I am. my boy just joined Scouts
and I got a list of gear.
I'm trying to figure out where to go and what to buy.
How can you help us out?
At KhanahoCreek. we've put together a scouting bundle
or, if you will, a beginning outdoor enthusiast bundle,
not just for Scouts but for anybody
who enjoys the great outdoors
and wanting to get into some equipment
that they can rely on.
and within that bundle we're willing at KhanahoCreek
to mix and match those components
to help fit your needs,
No matter where you are or what conditions
you're going to encounter.
Bill's going to help you out.
Go to KhanahoCreekcom
and there use the discount code CG113..
Thanks Bill,
Thank you Clark.
Look forward to talking to you next week.
In this podcast and Scout Master's Ship
in seven minutes or less,
we're going to be talking about four mistakes,
four pretty common mistakes that Scout leaders make
and some things we can do
to kind of perfect our leadership style a bit.
and then we have a couple of questions
in the email section
and that'll take care of this podcast.
so let's get started, shall we
Scout Master's Ship in seven minutes
or less.
Well, sometimes it seems we're doing all the right things,
but the results we're hoping for don't materialize.
When Scout leaders grow frustrated with their work,
it's usually because we're making one or more
of the following mistakes.
Number one is that we can tend
to become a little over-involved-
You've heard the term helicopter applied to parents
and teachers and Scout leaders
who are a little over-involved in their children's lives.
Scout leaders can over-plan.
we can seek to control too many of the variables
and we can reduce the scouting experience
to something more like a carefully guided tour
rather than an open-ended adventure.
We can become too driven by the concept
of educating Scouts to the exclusion of real growth.
Our honest good intentions sometimes
cause exactly the opposite results
that we were hoping for.
In our effort to protect our Scouts
from uncertainty and adversity
and to optimize the productive use of their time
and to develop balanced and healthy personalities,
we can undermine some important
natural developmental processes
that actually drive the results we're looking for.
Number two is we can become very risk-averse.
Our culture attempts to calculate and control risk-
and you know everybody does,
All cultures do-
But several factors
have distorted our perception of risk.
We have access to information on a scale
I would have to say that is just unprecedented
in human history,
but our ability to sort through that information
individually hasn't really grown proportionally.
Fear and foreboding
and highly attenuated emotions
are in the news all the time,
They're in entertainment all the time,
And new media just floods our screens
and airways with this.
Now, I'm not suggesting that this is some kind
of coordinated conspiracy or anything like that.
It's just human nature.
We simply don't get a balanced
journalistic report about a child being abducted
or abused or some kind of accident.
We end up being there watching the events unfold
hour upon hour,
And we just don't see the story once.
We see it hundreds of times.
If it gains enough attention,
we're likely to see it dramatized
in painful, lurid detail
on a television show or in a movie,
And communicating emotions on a visceral level
is, in many ways,
you know, the goal of everything
that we do as humans.
We want people to understand the way we feel,
and we want people to understand
the way things happen.
The problem is, we've become so good at doing it.
we can mistake emotion
for information.
These messages teach us mistakenly
that all risk is bad,
and our reaction is to reduce or eliminate
risk in our children's lives
in an attempt to make them safe and predictable.
We find out soon enough, though,
that it's really impossible to do
So. we resolve to control
more and more of the variables,
and this is more damaging
than protective.
If parents do this, and scout leaders
do it too,
Failure is that we misunderstand
the place of failure.
We've become so concerned about success
that we all have but eliminated
the risk of failure in many aspects
of our children's lives.
Failure is actually good.
Failure builds resilience and character.
Failure is not the enemy.
The enemy is shame
and anger
and discouragement
and disappointment in reaction
to things that don't go right.
Our scouts need the latitude
to attempt things and fail at them.
It's fine.
Whether or not our children
and our scouts learn from failure
hinges on our reaction to failure.
We probably all recall
some landmark in our childhood
experience where we failed
and the adults around us
reacted with anger or shame.
We don't want our own children
to experience this sort of thing,
so we either rescue them before they fail
or overcompensate by controlling
the natural consequences of the failure.
How we react to failure
is much, much more important
than rescuing our children from it.
Number four:
scout leaders tend to emphasize
rewards and we tend to lack
objectivity.
Scouting is not just a system
of challenges and rewards,
A list of things to do to get a badge.
It's a journey through
these important developmental
experiences.
We know success in life is not
a simple metric comparison
reduced to winning and losing right.
Our problem is
that in our parenting and leadership,
we can make it seem that everything
a child or a scout does
is measured and compared to others.
When this becomes the norm,
parents and leaders become cheerleaders
instead of coaches.
Now, our children and our scouts
both need encouragement
as either undeserved
or disingenuous.
Coaches, on the other hand, are pretty objective.
They help you find
your strengths and weaknesses and they give you
the tools to work with those strengths
and weaknesses.
Cheerleaders- not so objective.
They're always basically telling you
about how awesome you are,
Even when things aren't going very well.
parents and scout leaders need
to balance their coaching and cheerleading
to achieve real success
and real growth,
Those things that we're really driving at.
They must have a studied
and consistent objectivity.
Our children
don't grow, our scouts don't grow
and achieve because they are awesome-
Okay,
Even though
they are-
But they grow and achieve
because they learn to try
to overcome challenges,
to learn from failures
and learn to be persistent.
How do we avoid some of these common mistakes?
by balancing our leadership.
The overly effusive cheerleader
and the overly critical
taskmaster
are both ends of
an unbalanced spectrum.
Balancing our leadership style
is a never-ending challenge
and one that we should be working always
to improve. So here's some ideas
that you may think about.
Risk is not always dangerous.
Surely, some risks are unacceptable,
but not all risks are dangerous.
We have ample program guides
and rules that define the line
between acceptable and unacceptable risk.
Scouts need the latitude
to choose. Life is all about choices.
You choose to do something
or to be something,
But shaping and controlling every choice
to guarantee that it's a good one
is not a balanced approach,
Neither is having no control
over that whatsoever.
Every game has a field of play
and has a set of rules,
and so does scouting.
Some choices in scouting are simply out of bounds.
Some choices in life are out of bounds,
but if we eliminate possibility
of all the out of bounds choices,
we're not creating people with a resilient
character
or people who are able to make good choices.
I think another thing we can do
is have a lot of empathy,
and we need to have balanced empathy.
We're in danger of forgetting that our scouts
and think most adults are unerringly
sure of themselves
that we don't question or regret our own actions.
Letting them know
that we've fallen short at times
and that we've recovered
can help them better address
their own difficulties.
We need to be objective.
Our scouts are awesome.
Our children are awesome. We know it.
We know how intelligent they are
and what vast potential they have.
Of course, we know they can do great things,
but our greatness comes from hard work,
not from just being awesome.
Help them understand
that being talented
and skilled is only part of the equation.
The rest of it
is up to them.
Once we have that objectivity,
we really need balanced reactions.
We need to avoid being angry
and we need to be encouraging
and empathetic and understanding.
We need to balance rewards.
Every achievement is certainly a step forward
and every victory ought to be celebrated,
but it doesn't always have to be
a tick or tape parade down Main Street.
A few words of honest praise
mean a lot more
than that kind of showy
over excess.
And finally, we have to understand
that failure is not a bad thing
and it's a powerful teacher.
We know that achievement comes
more through hard work
than the force of somebody's personality
or awesomeness.
In the same way,
every failure is not caused
by a lack of personality or character.
Our job is to lend
every achievement and every failure
that objectivity
that will help our children
and our scouts grow into useful,
important human beings.
This is Cliff Jacobson,
and you're listening to the
Scoutmaster podcast
with Clark Greene
Email. that is folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
So
let's see,
I had this email
says I'm a scoutmaster
with a troop of 14 scouts
and I was planning
on trying to go to some of the local
churches and talk with their congregations
about scouting.
I thought it would be a great way to spread the word
about our troop to the community
and hopefully recruit a few new scouts.
but a lot of the pastors I've contacted
have not been very receptive to my idea.
Frankly, that's the opposite reaction
to what I was expecting.
I understand why the local school district
doesn't give us access,
but I expected local churches to maybe
be a little more welcoming.
Do you have any other ideas where I might go
to recruit new members?
Well, I gotta tell you that going out
and speaking to a church group
or a school group or something like that,
I'm not going to say that it's
unaffective and it's not a good way
to spend time. I think that it can
be a job of recruiting done,
but I wouldn't focus on that quite so much.
If you go to another community group
and you say I would like to come
and talk about my community group,
well that might be seen as
kind of treading on their turf a little bit,
especially with churches, with youth programs
and things. They may welcome you
and they may not. I wouldn't be surprised
if they don't. Here's my simple
recruiting formula. If you
distribute a thousand pamphlets
or handouts or something like that,
you maybe get three or four potential scouts
to attend a meeting-
Three or four out of a thousand.
If you go and you speak to a group of a
hundred people, you maybe get
one or two. If a scout
goes and talks to five
of his friends, one of them is going to come
to a scout meeting.
If parents talk to other
parents- let's say they talk to
five or ten other sets of parents-
you're going to get two or three.
you're going to get two or three
families who will send scouts to a meeting.
So if you just look at the ratios involved-
and hey, the ratios I'm giving you are
just kind of based on a seat of the parents,
estimate from my own experiences,
because I've tried all of those things
And the gold standard for recruiting
is scouts talking to their friends
and parents talking to other
parents, And it's hard to tell
which one is the most effective, but I know
that parents talking to other parents
is maybe just a little bit
stronger than scouts talking to
their friends who aren't in scouting. If I
was in the position of really wanting
to build up the troop and recruit a whole
lot of guys, I would spend my time
promoting
those actions that have the
best ratio of effort to results.
So let's get the scouts to talk
to scouts. Let's get our parents talking
to parents and see what happened. I got
this email from a scout
leader who said: I'm a little confused
about this because our scout
master distributed this memo
after our last camping trip
And the memo says: on our last
camp out, several scouts were sleeping alone
in their own tents.
Sleeping alone in your own tent is a no-no.
It's against the buddy system and youth protection.
Please don't do this
in the future. If there's an
odd number of scouts, they can
triple up in a tent. The practice
of sleeping alone in your own tent
leads to poor citizenship
and isolates the scout.
For instance, at Fillmont, if a scout needs
to get up and use a latrine at night,
he has to go with another scout.
The person who sent me the email
said: some of these things don't seem
quite right. Can you give me your opinion
on this.
Well,
that is actually a pretty bizarre
interpretation of the buddy system
and I think that the folks in your troop
may have gone just a tiny
bit overboard. So let's get some references
on the buddy system.
In the scout handbook, on page
39,, it says:
for many outdoor activities, scouting
uses the buddy system to help
ensure everyone's safety.
You and a buddy can watch out for each other during a camp
out by checking in now and again
to be sure everything is alright.
So let's note a couple of things out of that.
Many outdoor activities-
not all outdoor activities, it says,
but many outdoor activities-
and that you check in with your buddy
now and again to make sure everything is alright.
So that doesn't mean that you and your buddy
are necessarily constantly in each other's
field of view. The scout master handbook,
on page 99,,
when it's talking about gear
for scout troops,
it says two person tents are practical
for most patrol and troop camping.
They can be carried in backpacks
and are available with sewn in floors
and insect netting. Two scouts in a tent
can also strengthen the use
of the buddy system. Note that
that quote says
CAN strengthen the buddy system,
Not must or shall.
There's no dictation there
that the only way to do this
is to have a minimum of two scouts
in a tent. I mean it really
it's just kind of practical information
about having enough tents,
about being able to backpack with them,
and sharing two person tents is being recommended,
But it's in no way
required. If we look at the guide
to safe scouting, the buddy system
is explained this way: The long
history the buddy system in scouting has shown
that it is always best to have
at least one other person with you
and aware at all times of your
circumstances and what you're doing
in any outdoor or strenuous activity,
So that's someone
knowing where you are,
that you're okay, They are with you,
but not right next to you
holding your hand the whole time.
In inherently risky or
strenuous activities like swimming
and boating and climbing
and scuba diving and things like that,
the buddy system is a bit
different, isn't it? That's where you
absolutely have a buddy and you're
absolutely aware of each other
all the time, in every circumstance,
when you're in a pool, when you're in a boat,
when you're scuba diving, when you're climbing.
that buddy system
is a little more attenuated and a little
bit different than just the general buddy
system. going on, Now, if sleeping
in your own tent alone
leads to poor citizenship
and is an isolating experience.
I would guess that in this troop, the same
is true of the adult leaders, right?
I'm sure none of them sleep alone
in their own tents, because that would be
isolating and that would lead them to
being poor citizens.
Of course, all the scouts don't have their own
bedroom at home either, so they don't
feel isolated or turn into bad citizens,
right? I've been an adult
volunteer for more than 30 years now
and I've trained people in youth protection
and many other things more times than I can
count, and I have never, ever,
found anything remotely like what is
being described in this particular memo
in any of the literature.
If a scout shows up and he has his own
tent and would rather not have to share
a tent, I don't really see a problem.
99.99%
of the time when I'm camping
I have my own tent, I don't
share it with anybody else
and sometimes I'm a fair distance away
from everybody else. And as for what
happens at Fillmont,
scouts are advised to have someone else awake
and they need to use latrine at night. because why
There are bears in Fillmont
and bears wander around at night,
It's not because it's in danger of being
isolated or being a bad citizen,
It's just a safety measure.
Now listen, we can
tend to go overboard on things like
this because we think
if a little bit of safety is good,
a lot of safety keeps our boys
safer. So let's agree
that this is all coming from
good intentions, That the buddy system
is important and even required in some situations
And, like I said, Aquatics
is one of them. I think
some people assume that it has to be strictly enforced
all the time and in all situations,
and that is very right in theory,
but it's very wrong in practice.
So just to review, for many
outdoor activities, scouting uses
the buddy system to help assure everyone's safety.
You and a buddy
can watch out for each other during a
camp out by checking in now and again
to be sure that everything
is okay. Two person tents
are practical
for most patrol and troop camping
and they can strengthen the use of the buddy system.
but there's no standard being
dictated there And the long
history the buddy system in scouting has
shown that it's always best to have at least
one other person with you
and aware at all times of your circumstances
and what you're doing
in any outdoor and strenuous activity.
So the whole idea is that our scouts
look after each other, That they're aware
and responsible for the well being
of their fellow scouts.
Well, thanks for listening. Now here's how to keep in touch.
Read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can subscribe to the
Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and, when you do, please feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating.
You can also access the podcast
on your mobile device through
Stitcher Smart Radio
and get details about how to make that happen
as Stitcherio
and how to make that happen as Stitchercom.
ScoutmasterCGcom
is in the vast panorama
of social media.
That's right. You can follow us
at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
Tweet ScoutmasterCG on Twitter.
We have a ScoutmasterCG
circle on Google Plus
and there's plenty of ScoutmasterCG
pin boards at Pinterest.
You can always email me,
ClarkGreen, your comments and your questions
at ClarkCLARKE
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
ClarkCLA,
R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America
and they're not even endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America. It's just me.
I'm out here in the wilderness, talking into
a microphone, trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
Speaking of fun, here's our founder,
Sir Robert Biddenpal. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and group camping
Why? thank you, sir, Until next time
you.